[Laughter]
[Music]
these students had this really good idea
to work with bars in Florida in order to
take steps to help women get away from
dangerous situation so what they did is
they came up with this thing called the
owl shot and so for example if you order
I will shot meat to the bartender you're
telling the bartender that they need to
be escorted to their car the girl and
then if they order a owl shot on the
rocks that means that they need a ride
called for them however the bar chooses
to do so how do they get to the news
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's horrible shot it's like hard to
hear if you're if you're a bartender and
it's really loud and crazy in a bar
you're like should miss something more
this thing like lipstick
maybe Luther places have there's other
boys have done this it's called the
angel shot and they put the signs in the
women's bathroom like if you don't
exactly what it does gonna ask like how
do they get the women to know and not
the men to know but now that we all know
it's great but but there's a [ __ ]
thing to wear chicks can't order that
easily at a bar like guys who are
usually taller than chicks you could
just look at a bartender be like yo and
then they come and take your order so
like I'm probably gonna order for you if
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] like gave me an
eyelash up please yeah she said hey she
wanted me I know she went in the house
hop and then I'll get a box oh did she
want to neither this one under us
with lime means that this girl is in a
potentially dangerous situation and
would like the police to be called Jesus
she she doesn't miss ordering I'm like
what do you think he want oh [ __ ] I
don't know I'll just show up without it
and then I'll be like yeah I think it's
going on they're trying to keep you know
people say nope yeah but it is wow that
they they they post it on here cuz it's
like when when schools do the whole
training for school shooters and stuff
like that the school shooters do it I
know now he knows like he's not gonna go
try to go to library yeah like that on
Twitter I forgot how it was worded but
that's pretty much actually what the
message was it's like you know the
school shooter is in these drills yeah
most likely cuz usually it's the
students for sure yeah and they're
online too much I can't but I saw it
online it was a comic that's sad that I
feel like I might have been a comic
that's had that but it was just like
yeah you're teaching him the exact same
thing was it days about what it sounds
like I mean look I can still use this to
my advantage because if somebody's
bothering me and I'm at a bar I'm gonna
look right out and be like I'm bout to
order a novel shot sir like admit also
I'm thinking about this like wait Nicky
used to bartend right yeah like it's
already ordered an owl shot like I would
just feel I don't know well if there was
our bar that we would not be trained on
it but I feel like you can almost say
something to get out of that situation
too but yeah so what are you doing
tonight I don't know man I'll just have
crazy herpes outbreak today yeah so I'm
just kind of really dealing with that
thing makes it difficult to sit and lay
down yeah you know okay cool I'm uh I'm
gonna go ahead get up out of here
okay cool I wonder like I don't have
health insurance right now so I can't
get my prescription filled joking guys
don't care
listen I took a girl I took a group of
girls to Venice Beach and I set them
down on the bench and I rigged them up
so that when they're sitting there and
guys came up and started talking to them
and their girls like hey I don't know I
just had a lot of tacos I don't like it
I can't really talk right now
and I dressed them all hot and chin so
guys would sit next to them be like you
know like what's going on honey like you
look really cool and stuff like you
wanna hang out like hey I don't know
like so much pizza earlier like I don't
really think I should and because we
know you're fine and then also that oh
my god holy holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
and then I rig them up so that they hit
a little pump in their purse and they
would projectile [ __ ] explode
diarrhea all over the world yeah and
then the guys are like it's okay how do
you can come clean up my place yeah it's
a bunch of videos yeah they have
millions of views but that's the whole
point is right I knew that about guys
already that's why I set that up and
knew that the guys would [ __ ] we are
in the description awesome view okay but
I thought about the views I don't get
money from it anymore it's not about
that it's just about I know how guys are
they don't give a [ __ ] they they're like
go clean up and let's [ __ ] after well
then Gina I know you can think of
something right now that you can say to
a guy at a bar that'll make him leave
you the [ __ ] alone oh okay how about
this how much money do you have
hmm they don't care what about I'm
married like we'll be friends
[Music]
happily married I was like you don't
marriage worry have you ever been
married sir and then he's like no no
like no obviously
yeah I wonder your friend wait what did
this [ __ ] say it was in Beverly
Hills he this cop is not a cop like a
Beverly Hills Cop right a mall cop like
a security guard and he was walking me
across the street and I was like I don't
need help walking across my my old yeah
and then he was like oh can I get your
number and I was like oh I'm married and
like just brush it out like I've got a
hair appointment I'm married and he's
like oh okay I should want to be your
friend it's like no I'm I'm married I'll
have friends like
that exact situation happened when i
exac but a similar situation happen you
know we all went to comic-con and then
afterwards we you know we split up good
you guys went to a parking garage and
then I had to cross the street to get to
Mike oh yeah
during that crosswalk interaction but
one time you were alone the whole time
literally the only time I was alone this
one guy's like right net be standing
right next to me he's like hey um you're
really pretty
and then he goes so what's your name and
I'm like oh I'm married and he's like oh
hi married married he's like oh okay
well were you heading off to and I'm
like marriage home to my husband by
Nikki I won't say I think that you made
a mistake because it would be really
handy to know mall cop was like well he
could hang out too like oh my gosh about
this now yeah I never say anything
because I think I just I just look mean
and I'm just like I'm not [ __ ]
interested sorry yeah yeah some guys
like the main tip I like the challenge I
like I mean I like I mean yeah I like
him what they got a little scroll on
their back I bet I could make you laugh
that's annoying to me if I was like this
mom or a [ __ ] I can make you laugh I'd
be like I'm sure you can thank you
goodbye yeah I know I bought it yeah
here's like alright you're that checker
yeah your neck I love challenges six you
haven't just I think you know I think
though with like a guy finally will say
something like if you make eye contact
with them or if they just see their
opportunity like if you like mimic
emotion or do anything then they like go
in for the kill but you just cannot
engage just don't engage my contact is
like say some there was this one time oh
my gosh I went this is like so long ago
um I think I was like eighteen nineteen
and I went to this like really really
popular Banda Club what now funda pandas
panda Panda Express like a Mexican
I mean funda it's the type of music like
they took the word man and they just
added a to it yeah bandha bandha is your
nameless Wordsworth ban band cool thank
you I don't even know like my brain is
like like what cuz I just know it in
Spanish anyway so we go to this club
there's a lot of Mexican dudes you know
my cheese mo is really strong and that's
kind of community and so I was with my
girlfriend and we had just walked back
from the bar and then all of a sudden
this guy grabs my arm and I haven't been
grabbed before but it was like this one
was aggressive where I got actually
legit scared like the pulp scared
especially and at that age that tip was
so not confrontational I was in too deep
TIFF where I was just like I just
started smiling and I was like oh no
okay like no I'm good and then my
girlfriend's like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you get off for her whatever and
then the guys like yeah I don't know
what the hell he was saying he was so
drunk but he would not let go of me and
I was like this is [ __ ] scary and
then all of a sudden this other guy pops
up and he's just like hey man let go of
her or whatever and then and then this
drunk ass guy that was grabbing on to me
started having like an altercation
verbal altercation with this other guy
so then as soon as like he got
distracting he let go of my arm I was
like look at the [ __ ] out of here I'd
never been in that situation it was so
scary so I'm like dude like women go
through some [ __ ] up
it's Jurassic Park dude the - what
happened oh my god I can get away yeah I
think the worst is oh it's that there's
literally like guys that make an
internet business off of being like a
pickup artist oh my god they send these
men out into the Y week their fedoras
and [ __ ] like dude 900 doors like
sometimes they're just like yeah they
get a couple dating tips [ __ ] I know I
mean like I'm not mad at him you know
but I'm just like hey man just try
somebody else you know go go for
somebody oh I read that book it's the
[ __ ] pickup artists book or whatever
and just like if you need to hire a
pickup artists to teach you and talk to
me when you're a [ __ ] loser because
he teaches you things like
oh you have to neg a woman like [ __ ]
yes nagging is Helene look man better if
it was blonde we're sitting like that
hot you think you're higher up that hot
yeah yeah worse I've seen way harder
than you what's ridiculous first of all
you're assuming that I pride myself on
my looks only like that where I derive
my value I just look video also I just
googled someone who's way hotter than
you anyway we were talking about owl
shots here so I don't know I wonder it
like like I said earlier I'm like how
did they come up with owl being the best
term for this because it doesn't sound
like any other shot like oh like it
doesn't sound like any other shots I
feel like they were just in a board room
they're like fire off some names yeah
that one genius Jenkins thank me Jake
it's perfect name sounds like it out
means I mean our stands for out when
late
well when lately it's probably in the
article that old woman Molly's you
making me doubt myself it was really
good though
I delivered very well a lot of my Laza
but that you just have you order
something that nobody orders ever and
al-assad is something no one would order
but but that Salvage might make sense
also it there's [ __ ] trees got the
fuzzy navel there is yeah I'm saying
even a bulge on a fuzzy [ __ ] and all
kinds of skills popular if I'm not gonna
be fazed by it it is such a weird name
though that that would open the door for
me as a guy to be like oh what's in that
baby like hey give me a flamin hot how
about just charges that's what's in it
give me a flamin hot cheeto or something
something hasn't hasn't been designated
keen shot no don't get wet about it
supposed to be bad to know any what
about it
[Music]